we already know that in an electrolytic
cell current or movement of electrons is
used to drive a redox reaction and if we
look at a generic reduction half
reaction the stoichiometry of the half
reaction shows how many electrons are
needed to reduce a generic metal ion for
example if we say that our generic metal
ion is m2 plus it takes two electrons to
turn m2 plus into the solid metal so one
mole of m2 plus ions requires two moles
of electrons to form one mole of the
metal so we could use this mole ratio of
one mole of metal to two moles of
electrons to figure out say how much of
a metal is produced in an electrolytic
reaction so this is an example of a
quantitative electrolysis problem
moles of electrons are related to the
amount of charge that passes through the
electrolytic cell
because one mole of electrons carries 96
485 coulombs
so we could set this up as a constant
called faraday's constant so faraday's
constant is symbolized by f and it's
equal to 96
485 coulombs per mole of electrons
and charge is related to current and
time by this equation so i is equal to q
over t where i is the current q capital
q is the charge and t is the time
sometimes you see a lower case q for
charge
charge is measured in coulombs and time
is in seconds and one coulomb per second
is equal to one ampere so current is
measured in amperes
next let's look at a conversion chart
that shows how to approach quantitative
electrolysis problems and let's start
over here with this box on the far left
which says that charge is equal to
current times time this comes from our
equation for current i is equal to q
over t so solving for charge solving for
q
q is equal to i times t or charge is
equal to current times time
charge is related to moles of electrons
by faraday's constant so we can convert
back and forth between the two using
faraday's constant
and moles of electrons are related to
the moles of the substance that were
interested in the problem by the
balanced half reaction so the balanced
half reaction allows us to convert back
and forth between moles of electrons and
moles of substance and from
stoichiometry we know that the moles of
a substance is related to the grams of
the substance by the molar mass so the
molar mass allows us to convert back and
forth between these quantities so it
helps to look at a conversion chart when
doing these sorts of problems however if
you don't remember the chart you can
always use dimensional analysis and
units to figure out the answer to the
question
next let's use our conversion chart to
figure out a quantitative electrolysis
problem let's say we have an aqueous
solution of silver nitrate and a
constant current of
2.40 amperes is applied for
1225 seconds and our goal is to figure
out the mass of silver that is formed as
a quick reminder an aqueous solution of
silver nitrate contains silver one plus
ions and nitrate anions in solution so
the applied current is used to reduce
the silver one plus ions to form solid
silver and since our goal is to figure
out the mass of the solid silver that's
formed we're trying to find grams of
substance
and in the problem we're given the
current
and the time so we're starting over here
in the first box with the current and
the time
so let's think about the steps that we
need to solve this problem
the first step is to find the charge
which we can get from the current and
the time the second step is to convert
charge into moles of electrons from
moles of electrons we can convert that
into the moles of silver in this case
and in the fourth step for this problem
we can convert moles of silver into
grams of silver
so step one is to find the charge and q
the charge is equal to the current times
the time
so the current is equal to 2.40 amperes
and remember one ampere is equal to one
coulomb per second so we plug in 2.4
coulombs per second
and the time is
1225 seconds so we plug that in seconds
cancels out and we get that q is equal
to
2940 coulombs so that's the charge
that's transferred in that time period
now that we have the charge in the
second step our goal is to find the
moles of electrons and charge is related
to moles of electrons by faraday's
constant
so dividing the charge by faraday's
constant causes coulombs to cancel out
and we get .0305
moles of electrons and now that we have
moles of electrons in step three we can
find the moles of silver
looking at the balanced equation for our
half reaction showing the reduction of
silver ions
one mole of silver ions requires one
mole of electrons to form one mole of
solid silver
so our mole ratio of silver to moles of
electrons is one two one which gives us
this conversion factor of one mole of
silver per one mole of electrons so if
we multiply our moles of electrons by
our conversion factor moles of electrons
cancels out and that gives us
0.0305 moles of silver in this case our
mole ratio was one to one but if we were
reducing a different metal ion our mole
ratio might not be one to one so we have
to be extra careful on this step to make
sure we get the right mole ratio
and since we have moles of silver in our
fourth and final step we can convert
moles of silver into grams of silver so
multiplying moles of silver by the molar
mass of silver which is
107.87 grams per mole moles cancel and
this gives us 3.29 grams of silver
it's also possible to do all four steps
at once in a dimensional analysis
approach
so looking at our units if we multiply
1225 seconds by 2.40 coulombs per second
seconds cancels out and gives us
coulombs multiplying that by one mole of
electrons per 96 485 coulombs cancels
out coulombs next we have our conversion
factor of one mole of silver per one
mole of electrons so moles of electrons
cancels out and multiplying that by the
molar mass of
107.87 grams per one mole moles of
silver will cancel out and give us a
final answer of
3.29 grams so we get the same answer no
matter which approach we take